speaker i talked to one of the brilliant
young scientists
there and she described the most
extraordinary moment
for her in in her life to be part of an
enterprise
that was she thought truly going to
offer humanity
a root out of this suffering
but mr speaker we have to be realistic
and we have to accept that this vaccine
is not here no vaccine
is here yet and while all the signs are
promising
and almost every scientist i've talked
to agrees that the break shoe
breakthrough will surely come we do not
yet have
the one that has gained regulatory
approval we can't be completely sure
when the moment will arrive and until
then
we cannot afford to relax
especially during the cold months of
winter
the national measures which are now
shortly ending in england
have eased the burden on the nhs and
begun
to reverse the advance of the virus
today the r
is back below one and the ons survey is
showing that signs of the infection rate
are leveling off
uh imperial college london has found
that the number of people with covet
has fallen by a third in england since
the second
of november but while the virus has been
contained it has not been eradicated the
latest ones figures
suggest that out of every 85 people in
england one has coronavirus far more
than in the summer between
24th november and yesterday 322 people
across
the uk lost their lives
and despite the immense progress of the
last four weeks
our nhs remains under pressure with
hospitals
in three regions the south west the
north
east and yorkshire all treating more
covered patients
now than at the peak of the first wave
and i
give way uh to the honorable gentleman
and i thank the prime minister for
giving giving way
he did talk about the virus being
eradicated
only one virus in history has been
eradicated
containment may well be the only the
only
option open to us the honourable
gentleman is of course completely right
and
it is containment that is the objective
of the tiering scheme that uh
the government is uh is announcing which
i i hope that the
uh the bench's opposite will support uh
tonight in spite of the
the the what i i it gathers their
decision to abstain which seems
extraordinary
uh to me so so we can't simply
allow the current restrictions to expire
for the reason he gives with no
replacement whatever with the spread of
the epidemic varying across the country
there remains a compelling case there
remains a compelling case
uh for regional tears in england and
indeed mr speaker a compelling
necessity uh for regional tears and i i
give way to to my honourable friend
i thank him very much our latest rate is
79 for a hundred thousand a week ago it
was 178.
um we went in tier one we've come out in
tier two
my pubs and restaurants are in the worst
of all worlds
i wonder in asking me to support these
regulations tonight
what hope the prime minister can give to
them
well indeed mr speaker and i will be
coming in just a moment to
what we're going to be doing uh what
more we hope to be doing for
pubs and restaurants and everybody in
the hospitality sector uh who's
who's who's anguish and who's whose
difficulties i think
everybody in this chamber mr speaker
understands
and appreciates but i i hope the house
is clear what i'm
i'm not asking for uh today this is not
this is not another lock down uh nor is
this the
uh renewal of existing measures
in england the the tears that i am
proposing would mean that from
tomorrow everyone in england including
those in tier three will be free to
leave their
homes for any reason and when they do
they'll find the shops
open for christmas the hairdressers open
the nail bars
open gyms leisure centers swimming pools
open and i give way to my honourable
friend thank the prime minister for
giving away
my constituency of workington sits
entirely within the borough of allah
dale
where we've our rates have declined to a
point just over 70
currently in tier 2 restrictions will he
commit to a more local tiering system so
that the hard work of my constituents
is rewarded well yes indeed mr speaker
and i know that this is a point that
many of my honorable right honourable
friends have made to
uh to me and to the government with
great force and eloquence over the last
uh few few days we do want to be as
as granular as possible as we go forward
to reflect the
the reality of the epidemic and the and
the human geography
of the epidemic and we shall but what i
can what i can say
from uh tomorrow mr speaker is that
across the country across the whole
country
uh as i say uh not just gyms and leisure
centers and swimming pools but
churches synagogues mosques and temples
will be open
for communal worship organized outdoor
sport
will resume and in every tier you will
be able to meet others in parks
and in public gardens subject to the
rule of six
and every one of those things has been
uh by necessity
restricted until today every one of them
to be allowed again tomorrow and of
course i accept
that this is not a return to normality
i wish it was so but it is a bit closer
to normality than the present
restrictions and what we can't do
is to lift all the restrictions at once
or move too quickly in such a way that
the virus would begin
to spread rapidly again and that would
be the surest way
of endangering our nhs and forcing us
into a
new year locked down with all the costs
that that would impose and i give way to
the
honorable gentleman i thank the prime
minister and
after the inconsistencies and
controversies of the previous tiering
system
what was required this time around was
more fairness clarity and transparency
and we were promised a regional approach
however
what uh the powers of b have done is
that they have placed little old slow
in tier three despite the fact that we
have been segregated from the wider
region
and there are areas in neighboring
london and ethics
with higher covert transmission rates so
why does the prime minister hate slough
what what have we done to uh that has
annoyed him so much
but i understand what he's what he's
saying and i appreciate people's
feelings
of uh of injustice and people do feel it
there's no question people
feel that they've been unfairly
attracted uh
by proximity uh into a higher tier
than they deserve and and people also
feel
uh that they that they that the tearing
is not uh
working for them well i just want to
repeat the answer i gave to my
uh my honourable friend for from
workington uh which is that
uh as we go forward and i i mean this
very sincerely the government will
look at how we can uh reflect
as closely as possible the reality of
what is happening
on the ground for local people looking
at the incidence
of the disease looking at the the human
geography
and and spread of the pandemic and
indeed the progress
that areas are making in getting the
virus down and we will
try to be as sensitive as possible to
local effort and to local achievement in
bringing that pandemic
under control and if i'll just make a
little bit of progress
mr speaker because i want to say
something now about our hospitality
sector which i know the house
will want to hear because we all accept
that the burden on the hospitality
sector has been
very great and we feel this deeply
uh because our pubs are our
hotels restaurants they're in many ways
the the heart of our
communities and part of the the the
fabric of
of our identity as a country and
everybody can see
that so the hospitality industry has
borne a disproportionate share
of the of the burden in this crisis
there's no question
about it and that is obviously because
we want to keep schools open and mr
speaker
and and we have to take such measures as
we can i would just remind the house
however that we're not alone in this in
france
bars restaurants and gyms will not
reopen until
january the 20th at the earliest in
germany the hospitality sector will
remain closed in its entirety
over christmas but we will do everything
in our power
to support our hospitality sector
throughout
this crisis we've already extended the
fellow scheme for all businesses
until the end of march we've provided
monthly grants of up to three thousand
pounds for premises
forced to close and two thousand one
hundred pounds for those that remain
open but have suffered because of
reduced demand
we've allocated 1.1 billion pounds for
local authorities to support businesses
a particular risk and today mr speaker
we're going further
with a one-off payment of a thousand
pounds in december to wet pubs that's
pubs mr speaker that do not
serve food as as the house knows
recognizing
how hard they've been hit by uh this
virus in what is typically
their busiest month we will also
work with the hospitality sector in
supporting their advanced back
next year mr speaker i want to stress
that the situation is profoundly
different now because
there is an end in sight and i'm not
this afternoon seeking open-ended
measures
on the contrary these regulations come
with the sunset clause at the end of
february
and at that point we uh sorry at the end
of this at the end of the second of
february i should
i should say mr speaker and at that
point we will have sufficient at the end
of the second of february
we will have sufficient data to assess
our position
after christmas and though i believe
these types of restrictions
will be needed until the spring they can
only
be extended beyond the second of
february
if this house votes for the mr speaker i
give way with pleasure
market raisin ward in the week after
25th of november six cases to go to tier
iii east ham ward in london 40 cases in
that week to go into tier 2.
so what i want from my right-hand friend
is an absolute personal commitment
that he and his honorable friend the
secretary of state will look at this
personally
in the case of lincolnshire and they
will do their level best to get us out
of tier 3
by christmas
indeed mr speaker i i can i can
certainly give
uh my right honourable friend that
assurance that we will
we will look in as much granular detail
as we can at the incidents
throughout uh the country uh but i i
wish to
i wish and and the these are these are
points that have been made
uh with with with great power as i say
by
honorable members uh on all sides of the
house we'll
review the allocation of tears every 14
days
uh starting on the 16th of december
and i just want to make an important
point to to my right honourable friend
and to all members who are
rightly concerned about the position of
their constituencies our constituencies
in
uh in these tiers honourable members
have it in their powers in our power
to help move our areas down the tiers
by throwing their full weight mr speaker
throwing our full weight as leaders in
our communities
behind community testing
and seizing the opportunity seizing the
opportunity to encourage as many people
as possible to take part and i give way
with pleasure
to my right i'm very grateful to the
prime minister for giving way
uh kent is the the biggest county by
population
in britain and the reverse differences
in the rate of covid within it in
temperature wells we have one of the
lowest uh incidences in the country so
will the prime minister
uh commit that at it the first possible
review on the 16th of december
if a particular borough meets the
five criteria that he set he will move
it down
to a lower tier for that particular
borough
uh mr speaker i i'm i'm grateful to my
right on referendum
uh he's quite right to raise the the the
position of tunbridge wells and and the
feelings of the people of cumbridge
worlds i know
are shared by many people across the the
country who who
who feel this sense of as i say being uh
unjustly attracted into
the wrong level of tearing and i repeat
the assurance i've given
uh to my uh honourable friend from
workington and engagement
high school we we will look in granular
detail
uh mr speaker local incidents look at
the human geography
of the pandemic and take account of of
of exactly what is happening every two
weeks
as i say and it is in the power of
honourable members
to repeat my point uh to help
their local area move down the tiers i'm
going to give way
uh i think for one last time mr speaker
to the right honourable gentleman
i'm very grateful for the prime minister
giving way we ensure that
anyone who wants to take a test to
confirm that they don't have the virus
before they visit family members
over christmas can have a test on the
nhs
uh well mr speaker we're rolling out uh
lateral flow testing across the
the country and uh and anybody any
and it is open to people uh to get a
lateral flow test but in general
the testing system is available at the
moment for people
who have symptoms but i would i would
urge people who are
worried that they may need to uh be in
company of those who are
uh elderly or vulnerable to seek to get
a rapid turnaround test and i suggest to
him that one thing he could do
for his constituents if he wants to
to help them move out of the tier that
they are in
is to encourage them all to take part in
mass
community testing in mass community
testing of a kind
of a kind that the government is rolling
out and it depends very much
on the cooperation of local leaders
and local authorities of the kind that
we've seen
in liverpool mr speaker where since the
6th
of november over 284 000 tests
have been conducted and together with
the effect of national restrictions
the number of cases fell
by more than two-thirds and this is the
model that i
would recommend when i'm proposing that
from tomorrow liverpool city
region and warrington uh should be in
tier two whereas previously obviously
they were in tier three and we want
other regions and other
towns cities communities to follow this
path uh and that's why that's why with
the help of our fantastic
armed forces we'll be offering community
testing to
tier three areas as quickly as possible
mr speaker let me just say i'll give way
for
your weight my right number i'm very
grateful to the prime minister what
assessment has he done
of compliance with previous lockdowns
and does he share my concern
that people have just had enough and
that the risk of non-compliance is very
great
and that those who are compliant will
then have the added frustration
of watching those who won't comply doing
whatever they want
whilst they have to sit at home
mr speaker normally i find myself in in
agreement with my
my right normal friend but i must i must
say i don't think that she's right in
this in this instance because if you
look at what
the british people have achieved in the
last
few weeks by following the guidance
by deciding to work together to get the
r down they have done just that mr
speaker collectively the people of this
country
have got the r back down below one that
wasn't by non-compliance mr speaker that
was by the people of this country
deciding to follow the rules do it
together
and get and get the virus done and
uh i would just say mr speaker
that i find it extraordinary that the
official opposition represented by
uh the gentleman opposite currently have
no view
on the way ahead and not proposing uh to
vote tonight perhaps he'd perhaps you'd
like to tell us
well i'm very pleased to hear it uh many
of us on this side believe that there
should be restrictions but believe that
the prime minister's tears are wrong
he's
explaining very well there why he's
going to come back on the 16th of
december and come up with a system
that we might be able to vote for but
the system is coming up with today
is totally inadequate how is it possible
in chesterfield
with 118 per hundred thousand were in
tier three
but in london constituencies that he
represents a much higher level are in
tier two
it's because our pub owners and our
restaurateurs aren't worth it to him
well mr speaker i i i hope that the
uh honorable gentleman will really think
carefully about what he just said we're
trying to look after pubs restaurants
businesses across this entire country
and uh
and no no one feels the anguish of those
businesses more
than this government and i do i do think
however i do think it is extraordinary
that in spite of the barrage of
criticism that uh we
have uh we have no credible plan uh
from the party obviously indeed we have
no view we have no
view on the way ahead it's quite it's a
quite extraordinary thing mr speaker
that tonight
uh to the best of my knowledge the right
honourable gentleman opposite who said
he's always going to act in the
in the national interest has told his
party
to sit on its hands and to and to
abstain
in the vote tonight uh mr speaker and i
think
uh you know the government has made its
decision we've taken
we've taken some tough decisions uh mr
speaker
and the labour opposition has decided
tonight heroically
to abstain mr speaker and i think when
the when the history of this pandemic
comes to be written i think the people
of this country will
uh will observe that the instead of
having uh
politicians of all parties coming
together in the national interest they
had one party
taking the decisions another party
heroically deciding
to abstain uh mr speaker in
in the story of in the story of 2020 i
think there are two
great feats in which we can take a great
deal of comfort
first our country has come together in
an extraordinary effort that has so far
succeeded in protecting our nhs and in
saving
many lives and while our scientists have
been zeroing in on the weaknesses of
covid
telescoping 10 years of work into 10
months
uh and now uh their endeavors are about
to deliver
the means as i say to to route the virus
then that is that is clear
the government is backing not one
potential vaccine
but seven we've ordered 100 million
doses of the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine that's now seeking
regulatory approval we've ordered
seven million doses of the moderna
vaccine which has almost 95 percent
effectiveness in trials and mr speaker
we've ordered
40 million doses of the fisa beyond tech
that vaccine which uh if if approved by
the regulator
could start being administered but
before christmas
in total in total mr speaker no i'm
coming
in total mr speaker our vaccines task
force has secured
more than 350 million doses
more than enough for everyone in the uk
the crime dependencies
and our overseas territories all we need
to do now mr speaker is to hold our
nerve
until these vaccines are indeed in our
grasp
and indeed being injected into our arms
so i say to the house again let us
follow the guidance let us roll out mass
testing let's work to deliver mass
testing
to the people of our country let's work
together to control the virus and it is
in that spirit
that i commend this red these
regulations mr speaker
i commend these regulations to the house
the quest is that motion number three as
on the order paper can i just say to
members
i will be introducing a four-minute time
limit but i no go to the leader of the
opposition
here stammer
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker can i start by
welcoming the
full-in infection numbers the drop in
the number of people being admitted
to hospital and crucially that the
national r rate is now below one and
below one in
many parts of the country that is very
welcome
news across the house before this
lockdown
before the lockdown the infection rate
was doubling every two weeks
the r number was above one in every part
of england
and rising and the number of people in
hospital was going up sharply
across the country in other words the
virus had been allowed to get out of
control
and if anyone doubts that a lockdown was
necessary
i would point out that since the 2nd of
november when this lockdown started
seven hundred 10 eleven people have
tragically died within 28 days
of testing positive for covid19 in the
last week alone
that's an average of 460 deaths per day
that's appalling numbers and everyone is
a tragedy
so we can argue about why this lockdown
didn't happen
earlier when the infection rate was
lower as we argued for on this side of
the house
but whatever view whatever view was
taken of the
timing it's clear that the lockdown was
necessary
and has helped to reduce infections
mr speaker can i also welcome the
progress on vaccines
i have nothing but admiration for our
scientists and they've made
amazing progress that's been made and
this is a great moment for our
scientists i myself went to
oxford university week before last to
see the vaccine group there
and to see the remarkable work that they
were doing just before they announced
their
results so a vaccine may now be in sight
and we must do everything we can to
encourage take up
and make sure it's rolled out quickly
fairly
and safely but mr speaker the questions
before this house today are these
how can we save as many lives and
livelihoods as possible
until we reach the light at the end of
that tunnel and
are the measures that the prime minister
has announced today
going to control the virus and provide
the right support to communities
worst affected by these restrictions now
labour has supported the government in
two national lockdowns
and i recognize the need for continuing
restrictions
and i do recognize that the tears have
been toughened
as it was obvious to everyone that the
previous tears were a one-way street to
tier three
but i'm far from convinced by what the
prime minister has said today
in particular the economic package is
nowhere near sufficient
to support the communities most affected
and they've been suffering for many
months
i'll just make some progress now come
back i also fear that without the right
health measures in place
in particular a working trace and
isolate system
there are real risks that this plan is
incapable of controlling the virus this
winter
and i want to set that out in a bit more
detail before i do so i'll give way
i i'll thank the leader of the
opposition does my writing and boyfriend
agree with me that support for
businesses especially
in tier three who are struggling in the
hospitality and in the art sector in
specifically
uh is just not enough because many of
them are on the brink of collapse
to say to everybody in the chamber with
lots of speakers
those who run early intervening is not
fair to those later
people who aren't good to speak i do
understand need to intervene
but please let's think about each other
leader of the opposition
mr speaker i do agree i'll come to the
business support in a minute but let me
make the points
uh in support of the case we make today
and the first point is this
that we've been here before on the 10th
of june
the prime minister told us for the first
time of his whack-a-mole strategy
to control local infections the 10th of
june
he told us it would be so effective that
restrictions would only be for a few
weeks
or even a few days that was far from
reality
leicester for example has just gone into
the 154th day of restrictions
and by the time these regulations run
out on the 2nd of february leicester
will have been in restrictions for 217
days
so that didn't work that 10th june
proposal i will in just one minute
roll on to the 2nd of 22nd of september
by now infections rising in 19 of the 20
eras
then under restrictions the prime
minister announced new restrictions
including the rule of six he stood and
he told the house and i quote
that the rule of six he said this will
curb the number of daily infections
and reduce the reproduction rate to
below one that's what he said about the
rule of six
so that didn't work two weeks later
12th of october precise opposite
happening the prime minister stands up
again
third time introduces a three-tier
system again he said this will work
he told the house this will deliver the
reduction in the r rate locally and
regionally that we need
that didn't work 19 days later fourth
attempt now
a hurried press conference on a saturday
the prime minister announced
that the tier system had failed the
virus was out of crawl
control and a national lockdown was now
unavoidable
the reason this all matters mr speaker
because there's a pattern here
the prime minister's got a record of
over-promising and
under-delivering short-term decisions
that then
bump into the harsh reality of the virus
and then a new plan is coming up a few
weeks later we're now on at least the
fifth
with an even bigger promise that never
materializes
now after eight months after eight
months
the prime minister should not be
surprised that we
and many of the british people are far
less cons
convinced this time round i will give
way
i thank the honorable gentleman uh right
on germany hugely um
i have a biology degree and i'm going to
take a wild punt that i'm one of the few
members of this house that actually used
the word epidemiology in anger
before january this year and
we have choices to control this virus we
can have a lockdown we can have a tiered
system
or we can have no lockdown where lives
like john and ken
who are who we've just recently lost in
my family to this awful covert
have happened why will the right
honorable gentleman of the labour party
not support these measures that are
saving lives tonight
well i'm grateful for that intervention
i i'm setting out exactly why not
and i will take interventions along the
way so that what i say can be challenged
but the first point is which i just
finished that we have been here before
this is at least plan number five and
the first four haven't worked
so i think everybody would forgive the
british public for being
skeptical about the fifth plan and i'll
set out
i will go on to set out because the
second point i want to make
is this the public health risk of the
prime minister's approach
is significant the prevalence of the
virus remains
high even if the r rate is below one
it's only just below one
and we know that the virus is at its
most deadly during the cold winter
months
exactly when the nhs is under the most
strain
so if we're to keep the r8 below one
during winter
and not waste the progress that's been
made in the last four weeks
we need to proceed with precision and
caution
but instead of leveling with the british
public the prime minister spent the
weekend
telling his backbenchers that the plan
is all about in his words
loosening restrictions across the
country and he's been fueling a promise
that within two weeks or so local areas
have a real prospect of dropping from
tier one
dropping uh to a tier below the one that
they're in
we need to level in my view that is
highly unlikely and we might as well
face that now
it is obvious it is obvious that the new
that the new tier one may slow but it
won't prevent a rise in
infections and is far from certain that
the new tier two can hold the rate of
infection
i hear the mutterings but let's just see
where we are in two weeks and i
look across the house to members across
the house who think
that perhaps in two weeks their area is
going to drop down a tear just before
christmas
let's see this isn't hindsight i'm
telling you what's going to happen in
two weeks
[Music]
now we know where we will be we know
where we'd be in two weeks and i've no
doubt would be members on the opposite
side
getting up and saying i thought i
thought my area was going to drop a tear
just before christmas
that's not leveling that's not being
straight because that is not
going to happen tier one the new tier
the
tier one the new tier one may slow the
rate of infection
but it won't prevent it increasing and
tier two
will struggle to hold the rate of
infection i hope it does
i hope i stand here and i'm wrong about
this and i think all members hope i'm
wrong about
but tier two tier two
tier two or sunbrella it's a continuous
we've had it for a few weeks now let's
have a rest today
tier two crucially depends on all other
factors falling into place at exactly
the same
time and although everybody will welcome
the chance to see our loved ones at
christmas
i'm not convinced the government's got a
sufficiently robust plan in place
to prevent a spike in infections over
the new year now
of course this is difficult and all
systems would have
risk but that brings me to my third
point
the risks we face today in the decision
we make today
are much higher because the prime
minister has
failed to fix the major problems with
the now 22 billion pound track and trace
system before the prime minister simply
brushes the point
aside again let's remind him and the
house that one of the major regions
that reasons that sage advised this
circuit break back in september
was because track and trace was only
having in their words a marginal
impact on transmission so the great
thing that was going to control the
virus
wasn't working then and if we're to
control this virus
that really matters and the prime
minister having his head in the sand
isn't helping now i know the prime
minister will say
we've made advances in testing i
recognize that
and i genuinely hope it helps to tackle
the virus
but let me quote the chief scientific
officer
who said this testing is important
testing is important but of course it
only matters
if people isolate as well that's
blindingly obvious
but only a fraction of people who should
be self-isolating
are doing so and the prime minister
still hasn't addressed the reasons for
this
including the huge gaps in support
i know that there's been an announcement
about the change of those notified by
the app
a ridiculous admission in the first
place but it doesn't affect
basic eligibility only one in eight
workers
qualify for the one or five hundred
pound self-isolation
support one in eight qualify for that
support
anyone not receiving that has to rely on
statutory sick pay
which is the equivalent of 13 pounds a
day
that is a huge problem that needs to be
addressed
people want to do the right thing but
for many
there's a real fear that self-isolation
means a huge loss of income
that they simply can't afford now i
think and i can't prove this
that one of the main reasons that people
aren't passing on their contacts
in the way we want is because they fear
that those that they are passing on the
contacts for won't be able to afford to
sell
isolate that is a real problem and we
can't
carry on ignoring it i will
the right honourable gentleman is doing
a very good job it's his job to
criticize the government and of course
mistakes have been made but a credible
opposition has a plan of its own
what is the plan of the labour party
[Applause]
[Music]
just second by to the cherry is other
people as well please
just i'll come to that but i need to
i've accepted the case uh for
restrictions we were very clear about
the need for a circuit break we
clear we need to go into restrictions
but we need a scheme that works and i'm
explaining what the problem is with this
scheme
as we go through it because let me stay
with truck and trace
let me stay with truck and trace because
we know the claims the prime minister
made about this at the beginning
of the year in the middle of the year
because on tracing
on tracing crucial tracing
the latest figures show 137 000
close contacts were missed by the system
in one week
that's the highest weekly figure yet
this is not a figure that's going down
it's a figure that's going up that means
that over 500
000 close contacts have been missed by
the system in the last month
that's not a statistic that's half a
million people
who should have been self-isolating but
instead of self-isolating
they were with their friends their
families and their communities
half a million people in one month
that is a huge gap in the defenses
i raise this every week the prime
minister pretends it's getting better
but it never does i promise it's almost
given up on this
now and put mass testing in its place
again blind optimism
not a plan but the idea that we can go
through the next few months and
successfully keep the virus under
control
when 500 000 people a month are
wandering around when they should be
self-isolating
is not a sensible plan going forward
my fourth point is to come to the level
of economic support
that's provided i have to say to the
prime minister
it's hard to overstate the level of
anger there is about this
out there in our communities many of
whom have been in restrictions
four months on end yesterday i did a
virtual
visit to the north west to local
businesses there
their emotions range from deep
disappointment of the government
to raw anger that the prime minister and
chancellor just aren't listening
and don't get the impact of months of
endless restrictions
and the impact they've had on local
communities
in march the prime minister vowed that
the chancellor vowed to do whatever it
takes to support households and
businesses
but there's now been six economic plans
in nine months
and the level of support is still
insufficient
for these reasons and let me spell them
out
the go the prime minister mumbles let me
let me spell out
first the scheme doesn't fairly reflect
the difficulties facing businesses
across the country i'd be surprised if
members office
aren't picking this up from their
constituents and businesses
let me start with the additional
restrictions grant
which gives a flat figure to local areas
regardless of how long they've been in
restrictions
so that means greater manchester which
will be on its 40th day of severe
restrictions when it enters tier 3
tomorrow
has received the same one-off support as
the isle of wight
which went into restrictions far later
and will emerge tomorrow into tier
one that is unfair and everybody knows
it's unfair
and everybody in this house is being
told by their constituents and by their
businesses
that it's unfair so to pretend it isn't
there just isn't real prime minister
the second aspect i'll come to that
aspect the second aspect is this
the grant doesn't take account of the
number of businesses
that need support in each area so our
great cities are being asked to spread
the same sum
far more thinly and that's also clearly
unfair our constituents know it's unfair
our businesses know
it's unfair and nothing has been done
about it
the third aspect even allowing for
today's announcement on pubs which i
think is the definition of small beer
many businesses are now receiving less
support than they did during the first
wave
that's a huge strain for businesses
particularly
those that have been so long under
restrictions and it makes no economic
sense for the government to allow them
to go to the wall
the second putting putting the grant
system on one side
putting the grant system on one side the
second major point about the economic
support is this
that millions of self-employed people
remain unfairly excluded from the
government support schemes
again there's nothing that's been done
about this i've raised it so many times
with the prime minister serve others
every time he chooses to talk about
those that are within the scheme
ignoring those that are not in the
scheme this is eight months on
uh and we're facing another three or
four months of this which means
12 months without the support that's
needed in those areas
i work extremely grateful to the right
honourable gentleman for for giving way
he talks about those people being
excluded from support and focusing in on
who those people
are they include people who set up their
own businesses 18 months ago directors
are very small limited companies taxi
drivers
uh hairdressers and the like these are
the entrepreneurs we
need to build britain back as we recover
from the economic wreckage
of the corona virus does he agree with
me we should be investing in those
people
not excluding them and leaving many of
them in deep and dangerous
debt i i do and
um their cry still hasn't been heard now
i accept that
in putting together a support package in
a hurry back in march
there may have been reasons why certain
groups were overlooked
but this is eight months on this has
been pointed out over and over again and
here we go into a tiered system
and there's still that gap in the system
and it's being very strongly felt
out there the the third point about the
economic package is this
that the government must remove the
uncertainty about furlough
and rule out changing the scheme again
in january this is crucial
because businesses are beginning to make
decisions about what they do in january
the chancellor made this mistake before
by the time the furlough was extended
many businesses had laid people off
because it came too
late we know what happens in this
circumstance the uncertainties already
caused
real economic damage and we can't afford
the same mistake
again so taken together the business and
economic support
just doesn't stack up i want to make a
wider point about the economic damage
that this pandemic and the government
have done to our economy
last week's autumn statement laid bare
the huge and worsening economic cost of
the crisis
i know that there are those that say
well that's the reason to end
restrictions
but the reality is you can't protect the
economy if you lose control of the virus
that just leads to more uncertainty more
restrictions
and more long-term damage the economy
and it's the failure to get control of
the virus or take a long-term approach
to shielding our economy
that's left the uk with the worst
economic recession of the g7 and the
highest death toll
in europe the fifth reason for
skepticism about the government's
approach is this
managing and priorities the last 48
hours have been a summary of the
mistakes the government's made
in this crisis the prime minister is
fatally split between appeasing his
backbenchers
and following the science and he's
ending up pleasing nobody
i think the prime minister knows that
tough restrictions are now needed
but he pretends but he he pretends
he pretends that the restrictions might
not be in place
for very long he pretends that it's
quite possible
that everybody will be in a lower tier
in two weeks time the reality is that
tough restrictions will be needed
until the vaccine is rolled out that may
be months
away the prime minister will doubtless
be back in a few weeks with another plan
but the prime minister doesn't make that
case today or provide the certainty
or the consistency that we need so in
the last 48 hours
we've had concessions letters and
promises to his mps
not clear and reliable messaging to the
public and that's symptomatic
of the problem mr speaker
coronavirus remains a serious threat to
the public's health
to our economy and to our way of life we
recognize the need for continued
restrictions
but it's not in the national interest to
vote these restrictions down today and
we will allow these restrictions to pass
but it's another wasted
we accept the case for restrictions we
want a plan that's going to work we're
on plan
five and this one's full of holes we
have been there so
so many times so many times the prime
minister stood there and said
this is the plan this is the plan this
will solve the problem
fifth time round still a plan with holes
that have been there for months
and still not close why is track and
trace still not working
why are the gaps in the support still
there why are those that are excluding
not included
why are those that have to self-isolate
not given the support to do so
these are huge gaps in the system and to
simply vote through a plan
without recognizing those problems is
not going to help now
i accept the case for restrictions we
will not stand in the way of these
uh regulations we do not want the
restrictions to come off but i'm not
going to stand here and pretend
as the prime minister does that this is
the plan that's going to solve it all
vote for this and it'll all be fine
through to easter that is not
going to happen and nobody should vote
on that basis today thank you mr speaker
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker and i have to say
that
while there are many points of merit
that the right honourable gentleman has
just raised
uh he's left the house and the public
with the impression
that he is happy for these restrictions
to go through he just won't vote for
them and i think that the
the idea that that's the kind of
atmosphere that the public wants
or will encourage the public to comply
and to cooperate when there is
disagreement between the main parties on
these fundamental issues that can't be
resolved in a sensible way
i think uh the public will be
disappointed with that
and i'm grateful well there might be a
different interpretation of the events
that were just passed mightn't there
which is that
a lot of us are very concerned that the
prime minister doesn't give the full
story
to the house and to the nation the truth
is we're almost certainly going to see
another lockdown in january aren't we a
full lockdown across the whole of the
united kingdom
the chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
i hear the prime minister say it's not
what we want
nobody wants any of this of course we
don't but we have to be
honest and straightforward with the
british people and these measures today
are not sufficient to today i i didn't
hear my right honourable friend
make the promise that he is suggesting
that he made
um i think my right-hand girlfriend is
being perfectly honest with the house on
this
i think it's very difficult i'll come to
the point but i want to concentrate
on what we agree about we all agree we
want to keep the r rate below one
while minimizing the restrictions on
people's lives and limiting the economic
damage
if the rx rises above one then this
becomes much too difficult
to predict and control it has a
multiplying effect even if
the r rate remains constant and it's
perfect legitimate for colleagues
on this side to press the government for
more clarity about why the government
believes the nhs
is at risk of being overwhelmed data for
much of the country does not suggest
that at the moment
but it's not uncommon for hospitals to
become overrun during the winter months
and without that's without the addition
of covid it's also reasonable for
government to feel
the rising rate of covert infections
would lead to exactly that in some areas
or much worse
unless we can keep the our own our
number
around or below one and that's all that
these measures can be expected to
achieve
it's right to press the government for
more analysis
of the economic impact of these measures
but maybe the government was wrong
to raise the expectation that they could
provide this degree of certainty
where so much uncertainty exists equally
it must be agreed it is impossible to
predict the economic consequences
of a rapid spread of the virus and i
understand the frustration
of representing a low virus constituency
but included
in a tier two area and the need to
provide the right support to business
being badly hit
but these are not about alternatives to
the fundamentals of this policy which i
believe
the opposition is trying to avoid the
real question is
and it's an also a legitimate question
is will these tiers be enough
i hope tier 2 tier 2 will keep essex
below the r 1 but there is doubt
tier 2 did not work before we must look
upon this period
as a further period of transition to
when vaccines will begin to become
available
we should look ahead at the challenges
the vaccine programs will present
and give thought to how we will provide
reassurance that the vaccine
that you are being invited to accept is
right for you
and in the meantime the challenge is to
ensure that we can
move down the tears not just into tier
one but to remain in tier one
even if the vaccines take time to become
effective and at scale
and this will depend upon how we all
behave and the example that we set
and what we do to encourage confidence
and cooperation with tests and trace
operations
there is much to ask the government
which time does not allow today
about how to improve trust trace and
isolate operations
particularly at local level and about
how the community volunteer hubs
could help support people who should
isolate
that is vital work now the last thing
i want is to vote for these restrictions
today
but until there are better alternatives
we have
no alternative and should support them
and i'm sorry that her majesty's
opposition are trying to avoid that
truth
the government has also the opportunity
to learn
by continuing to listen and to gain
public confidence from that
patrick grady thank you madam deputy
speaker
the motions before the house do relate
exclusively to
england but that doesn't mean they don't
have consequences across
these islands and so it is important i
think that the voice of the scottish
national party is heard
in this debate although in line with our
long-standing practice
as regards matters that are devolved we
won't take part in any division
this evening and i'm sure that's of some
assistance to the government equipment's
office
and perhaps the first thing the
government needs to consider is
why it has got to that stage scotland
has passed
similar but not identical regulations
with a far
greater degree of cross-party and
intra-party
consensus than seems to have been
managed here in westminster
and perhaps that's because the first
minister and her cabinet secretaries and
the senior public health officials
have always taken a commendably frank
and honest approach
with the people of scotland about the
challenges of the virus and the
difficulty of the decisions
that have to be made in the summer time
the first minister initiated a national
dialogue
with people across scotland on what a
roadmap out of the initial lockdown
should and could look like instead of
promising moonshots and
world beating systems and that it would
all be over by christmas
the scottish government and the other
devolved governments
have worked to take people with them
whether that's the public at large
or whether it's their own back ventures
and we've always been clear
that public health and saving lives has
to be
the priority whatever the pain and there
is real pain
caused to the economy and livelihoods by
these kind of restrictions
that pain is as nothing to a life ended
too soon to a family or a community
bereaved by this dreadful disease and as
always the scottish national party
sends its deepest sympathies to all
those who have lost a loved one
as a result of the pandemic but that's
not to minimize the impact and effects
of the economic pain i see it firsthand
in glasgow north which thrives on the
hospitality
and entertainment and events sector and
will be interested to find out what the
consequences of the government's
announcement today about support for
pubs will be north of the border
my constituency is home to thousands of
creatives of startups of entrepreneurs
who have all been left behind forgotten
excluded
from the chancellor's support package we
hear the impact from the families
genuinely terrified that the 20 pound
universal credit uplift
will not be extended beyond march and
from those on legacy benefits
who have yet to see a similar uplift and
we all feel the struggle
of the frontline public sector workers
busting a gut
to keep the services that we all depend
on going in the most difficult of
circumstances
and support for all of these groups and
for those who need to isolate
which is absolutely critical to stopping
the virus in support for these groups
the government has been found wanting
the prime minister was juncturing to the
leader of the opposition
saying how do we get people to
self-isolate well as he said
start by paying a decent rate of
statutory sick pay make it affordable
for people to stay at home
and stay safe and perhaps if the
government had made more effort to
support those people to support the
excluded
to support families who are struggling
then it wouldn't be feeling the heat
that it is now from its own back benches
and we just imagined that please speaker
need to compare that to what we've heard
in the last few days in scotland a 500
pound bonus
for all nhs and social care staff for 10
weeks
we all clapped for carers but that was
never going to be enough and this is a
gesture of thanks
for extraordinary service and i really
hope the prime minister and the
chancellor will have the decency
not to level tax on this well-deserved
reward
and for the families who need it most a
100 pound
one-off payment before christmas to
household with children
in receipt of free school meals and a
commitment that all primary children
will receive free meals breakfast and
lunch at school and all year round
if the snp is re-elected next year
that's the difference
the devolution makes for nhs workers the
families and receiving these payments
that's not a disaster that's a scottish
government working for
and delivering for their best interests
and the interests
of our society as a whole and if it
means that we are using our share
of money that the uk treasury has
borrowed on scotland's behalf
well that's the point of devolution and
the tories don't like it and i hear some
juncturing the solution is very simple
independence for scotland would have
meant we could have raised our own
finance on our own terms and spent on
our priorities
in our own time and we certainly would
have had to wait for the southeast of
england
to be placed into lockdown before the
furlough scheme was extended
across the whole of the uk so madame
deputy speaker if the prime minister is
feeling pressure from his own side today
he only has himself to blame real
leadership
is about being able to make the hard
choices and be honest with people
when mistakes are made especially in a
time of crisis
people don't want bluster and false hope
they want honesty
and determination and empathy
the governments the devolved governments
have always sought a four nations
approach
wherever possible and we've seen that
agreement can be reached in the
provisions being made
for those who need to travel to see
loved ones over christmas
and while that period of easing will be
welcomed by many all of us will have an
extra responsibility
to be extravagant to minimize risk to
practice social distance our good hand
hygiene wearing our face coverings
and all the other steps that we've
become familiar with
but that familiarity cannot become
complacency
the threat to the threat of the virus to
overwhelm our health service to
undermine the economy
and to individual lives across the
country has not gone away
so while we welcome the light at the end
of the tunnel as vaccines come online
that light must be approached slowly and
carefully
so that's why scotland will continue
with its tier system and the difficult
decisions
that we need until the virus is beaten
the other devolved nations
are making similar decisions and members
representing england in this place
have a responsibility to do likewise
yeah yeah
so graham brady thank you madam deputy
speaker can i say
at the outset that i think the prime
minister's instincts
in this matter are not so different from
mine
and i recognize the difficulty and the
burden that he
uh carries this is a difficult matter
and there are difficult
uh decisions to take freedom
madam deputy speaker is not an absolute
but it should
be regarded as precious and it should be
always the strongest possible
presumption
in its favor if government is to take
away
fundamental liberties of the people whom
we represent
they must demonstrate beyond question
that they are acting in a way that is
both proportionate
and absolutely necessary today
madam deputy speaker i believe the
government has failed to make that
compelling case the benefit of the doubt
that this house
has extended to government in march and
since
is harder to take for granted in
december
madam deputy speaker six weeks ago many
of us made the case
that the curfew policy at 10 p.m
was not just unnecessary but that it was
counterproductive
today the government apparently agrees
that the 10 pm curfew
makes no sense a month ago the
government insisted
that golf and tennis and bowls and gyms
were unsafe now seems that they're not
mr madame deputy speaker before the
second lockdown
i invited the house to consider whether
government had the right
to make it illegal for people to see
their children
their grandchildren or their elderly
relatives
whether government had the right to ban
collective worship
or to take away the right to work to
support
your family different people different
members of this house
will draw the line in different places
but we must
all accept that these are fundamental
freedoms
of our constituents and we should insist
on compelling evidence
before we allow them to be compromised
that is why
madam deputy speaker i asked for an
impact assessment
a month ago and also for a transparent
publication of the criteria that would
be used to decide
in which tier our constituents would be
placed
but also crucially the weighting that
would be applied to each of those
uh criteria madam deputy speaker
my constituents in the borough of
trafford have been placed
unfairly in tier three in spite of covid
test figures
that are well below the average for
england
currently the race 127.7
for a hundred thousand and falling
rapidly
but i looked in vain at the document
published late
yesterday for any explanation
or any route being set out as to how we
would reach
that low tier there was no serious
attempt
in that document to provide an answer
in the absence of that serious and
compelling case
then deputy speaker i have no choice but
to oppose these measures
hillary man thank you very much indeed
madam deputy speaker i would say to the
right on the gentleman for aldringam and
sale west that this
debate is indeed about freedom but it's
also about the balance
of risks and costs the risks to life and
the costs to businesses and families
which are both substantial and deeply
worrying to every single member
of this house but it's also a debate
about facts
what are the facts and here we know that
our debate in this country and indeed
across the world
about how to handle this epidemic is
disputed by some
and it is a dispute in which the truth
and the uncertainty because some of this
is
all about scientific uncertainty wrestle
with the plainly
force and it is about the impact of that
on vaccination
that i want to say a few words today for
months now we have lived
through restrictions we have seen people
die we have seen our local businesses
suffer and from time to time we have
lifted our eyes to the horizon in the
hope of glimpsing something
that is a bit better well um
something has now appeared to use a
seasonal analogy in the dark winter sky
there are three new stars have appeared
and they are the three
new vaccines which have been developed
and awaiting
approval and as it's been said already
every single one of us
owes an enormous debt of gratitude to
the scientists and the volunteers who
took
part and to all of the people in the nhs
local authorities our forces and others
who as we speak are making preparation
for the mass vaccination program to come
but that too is disputed by some
people although i think it's really
important madam deputy speaker we
distinguish
between the conspiracy theorists
anti-vaxxers
on the one hand and those who have
genuine questions and concerns
on the other now it may seem incredible
to every single one of us
that there are people who believe those
conspiracy theories one of which
apparently is that governments wish to
inject us all with microchips given the
problems they've been with
handling other aspects of the epidemic i
don't think any government of the world
would have the capability to do that
it is of course complete nonsense but
more seriously
we remember the huge anxiety that was
caused by the
false claim that
autism was caused by the mmr vaccine
now that study was eventually
discredited the doctor responsible
struck off but the damage
had been done and the anti-vax
conspiracy theorists are still touting
their lethal wares around the internet
the fact is that vaccination has saved
millions and millions of lives since
edward jenner
developed the first successful vaccine
in 1796
and in the last 30 years vaccination
against polio
has almost eradicated that terrible
disease they're just two countries left
in the world
where it still exists pakistan and
afghanistan and that
is in parts down to some people who have
killed brave health workers who were
only trying to save the lives
of children and therefore anything and
everything and i say this to the health
secretary
that can be done to take on those who
spread
falsehoods will have the full support
of this house but it is also a fact
that there are people who have genuine
questions and concerns and i just
say it's really important that we
provide as much information as possible
so people can weigh up the facts talk to
their gps and make a decision
now i welcome the decision that
vaccination will not be
compulsory it should not be compulsory
but nor should we forget that it is both
a fact and the truth
that the more of us who are vaccinated
the better the chance we have
of defeating this disease so madam
deputy speaker subject to the regulators
saying they are safe
i for one will be queueing with my
sleeve rolled up when the time comes
david davis the uh bridal gentleman
leaves me with an interesting image to
uh
to start my uh speech let's look at the
facts madame david speaker the
government tells us that this is all
about
protecting the national health service
fine
so let's start with the hard uk numbers
the number of covert 19 patients in
hospitals reached a peak
of 16 612 in the uk
out of 127 000 hospital beds nationwide
a week or two ago number of patients in
critical care beds reached a peak of 1
489 with a uk wide capacity of at least
4
500. and at the recent peak of the virus
the national health service had 13 000
free hospital beds
and 18 of critical care beds free which
is better than it usually is
at this time of year significantly
better
so of course a concern because of the
potential growth of the virus but not
cause for panic now the government
undoubtedly has to act
but it should do so on the basis of hard
facts
what we're talking about today of course
is what the government thinks of as a
localized lockdown tiers one two and
three
but we know from other studies around
the world other countries around the
world
what does work and what does not we
don't have to guess
there's actually hard evidence some of
the select committees
have covered that hard evidence what
does work
is very very narrowly targeted
inventions
with intensive testing and tracking of
contacts and highly
localized lockdowns highly localized
lockdowns
take germany who have their fair share
of densely populated areas
but have a death rate of one quarter of
ours
their concept of a local lockdown may be
the at the biggest the city of goodison
with a population of 101 000 of iron
doors 37
000 or one meat packing factory seven
thousand or even one block of flats
700 people that's what they think of as
a localized lockdown
compare that to us we lock down
liverpool city region
one and a half million greater
manchester 2.8 million
yorkshire and humber 4.7 million
anything but a precise lockdown
other countries as well like south korea
and vietnam have used a similarly
targeted approach
to contain the virus for spectacularly
better results than we have achieved
south korea has just 10 deaths per
million of population
vietnam is even more successful with
about half a death per million for
population
now these measures will undoubtedly go
through today but i will not
be voting for them when we come to vote
on them i'll expect that next time
in uh in early february according to
prime minister i will hope
they'll be massively more targeted
restrictions on the local authority
level to what we have now is not enough
we must follow the example of germany
south korea and others by having
restrictions imposed
on a much smaller area they work better
they're fairer and they cause much less
economic damage we don't know for sure
but the blanket lockdown restrictions
work to suppress the virus
but what we do know for sure is the
economic damage
caused by such restrictions the impact
on people's livelihoods
and even their mental health is
absolutely clear
as my honorable friend the chairman of
22 said earlier
in this country we do not give up our
freedoms lightly
what we need today is a policy of
maximum protection
for minimum damage this policy is not it
i hope the next iteration in february
does a much better job
graeme stringer it's a pleasure to
follow
the right honourable uh gentleman i have
to say
i agree with him and i will be voting
against uh these regulations
uh this this evening but he has
persuaded me to change what i was going
to
say by the power of his uh speech
because we don't have to look to germany
and vietnam
uh to see what it is necessary to do we
have to look at 200 years of public
health
in this country which has always been
done
at a local level and one of the problems
with the systems that the government
have
followed like all governments they want
to centralize things
they want to take control and it is not
just the fact uh that people suffer
financially
and won't isolate themselves it is that
the central system is so slow
at getting the information out to people
that they need to isolate
that by the time it's got there the 22
billion pounds or whatever we've spent
on it
has been wasted it's gone the
information is useless
and in actual fact we have also seen
evidence that public health england
have withheld information uh from local
public health authorities so if we want
when we come back in
uh two months time to get it right we
must decentralize the expenditure and
get it into local
uh public health systems what i was
going to say before the right honourable
gentleman spoke
was that there isn't a way forward where
people don't die
in this situation that's tragic and
everybody in this house
wants to minimize the number of deaths
but we sometimes speak as though
if we uh if we have the most restrictive
measures which will undoubtedly
stop people contracting covid
that that will be fine it's not
the first lockdown led to people dying
from cancerous cancer services were
withdrawn
people didn't go to hospitals and if
they did go to hospitals they
often didn't get treatment the number of
people
dying at home increased dramatically
over that period so the proposals before
us today
uh will lead to more of that withdrawal
of the health services
from some people they will be
extraordinarily
damaging to the economy of greater
manchester
and other parts of the united uh kingdom
economy and remember poverty kills it's
not just
cancer and covetous kills poverty kills
people commit suicide children who have
had their
education withdrawn suicide rates
amongst children are up by 40 percent
so there is huge damage done
across the board and if we look at the
basis of the decisions
uh people say that it's been informed by
the science
well i can't see that when we had the
secretary of state
uh for health before the joint
committees of health and science on the
23rd of november
and we asked him about
what criteria was going to use to
determine
which areas went into which tier he
couldn't tell us has there been a
cost-benefit analysis
he could tell us because greater
manchester leaders
told him that he'd got his figures wrong
that any fact
he didn't use the word punish but in
fact greater manchester was going to be
punished
for taking time to put him right on the
science and the detail
of what was happening in greater
manchester when it came to
consider i will give way to the right on
the gentleman
i want to help him with his time but
just to say to him this that
uh the science is not the same as the
opinion of a single scientist
agree more and one can go right away
from the barrington group
to the people advising the government if
you have
science to send a rocket to the moment
it is exact
the science on epidemics is not exact
there it is
it is open to different opinions
what i was going to finish on i think
the secretary of state showed his
prejudice against greater
manchester and the proposals he's put
fold will
wreak economic havoc on on greater
manchester and we are told although
we clearly weren't present that when the
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
was making his proposals to lock down
london the prime minister
ex-mayor of london said no you can't do
that it will cost half a million jobs
and what that means to me is this
government uh
valuing jobs in london over jobs in
manchester and elsewhere it has been
through
we're going to interrupt our coverage of
the debate in the house of commons to
bring you some breaking news
from germany a car has driven into a
pedestrian zone
in the southwestern german city of tria
at two people
have been killed and fifteen others have
been
seriously injured the driver has been
arrested according to trier police
emergency services
are on the scene and the authorities are
telling people to
avoid the city center let's bring in
our europe correspondent adam parsons
now for more
on this adam thanks very much for
joining us
what more can you tell us about this
developing story
yeah very uh serious and troubling story
as you said uh
developing minute by minute but uh it
would appear
that a large car potentially rate
actually a range rover drove into a
pedestrianized zone
in in trier and knock down
a series of people i've seen figures
ranging from
a dozen into tens of people
before coming to a halt now suggestions
are that it was the car was rammed by
two police vehicles uh and and pushed
off to the side of the road
the driver we understand has been uh
apprehended the police say that they
have forgot him and of course they have
uh the stricken vehicle but the number
of
injuries was initially put at ten it may
be that that is rising the first thing
the police said there
uh was that there were several injured
uh they have now said that they believed
that two people
are dead and that there are clearly more
than three
injuries now now we have to be careful
here clearly at the moment
we don't know what caused this we don't
know whether this was a
a terrible traffic accident or perhaps
something more
sinister it is fair to say that uh
across much of western europe there is
nervousness
at the moment after several terrorist
incidents particularly in france
and of course one in austria recently
uh trier is what a couple hundred miles
from
luxembourg germany has not been
hit by terrorist incidents or anything
like the same way that particularly
let's say france's as i say at the
moment we simply do not know we have no
clarity
uh on the cause of this incident but
clearly
very very serious trio police telling
people to stay
away from the area uh and
considerable fear there about what was
behind this
and also about the injuries and deaths
that have been caused
yeah we're getting updates on twitter
from the police in trio
that is that the method of communication
at the moment adam but
but stressing that the care for the
injured is the absolute priority a news
conference expected at some point
but we can see from those pictures from
the last
few minutes adam a large emergency
service presence
uh at the scene in that uh what looks
like a pedestrianized area there
and and or a christmas market
yeah that's right i mean clearly germany
has
uh has a great fondness a great
tradition of christmas markets
and of outdoor shopping this time of
year now that has been
restrained by covid restrictions
which you see clearly across all of uh
europe but there are many german cities
which have large pedestrianized
areas what has happened here is that
this car
has gone into this pedestrian ice area
and has
frankly knocked people over as it has
gone through before coming
being brought to a halt and i think this
will in many
people's minds bring back uh memories
of previous incidents where vehicles
have gone into terror
have gone into pedestrianized zones
knocked people over
and caused some pretty horrendous
injuries we've seen that happening of
course
in the uk and across europe so
whatever the cause of this and as i
emphasize it it is still
too early by far to make any kinds of
uh of analysis without any in-depth
information
uh it's certainly going to provoke in
people's minds
i think memories of previous terrorist
incidents
and i'm sure that there will be many
wondering whether this was such a thing
or was
this simply a terrible road traffic
accident
and one person has been injured the
driver sorry one person has been
arrested uh adam the driver arrested
according to the police at the scene
yeah the uh the the driver uh clearly
uh whatever the cause of it has gone
through
these people now i i don't know the city
but i've read up about it
uh and people say it is very clear that
this is a pedestrianized air it's not a
sort of gray zone where
some vehicles come in some don't this is
a clearly demarcated
uh pedestrianized zone some of the uh
the footage that
has been put on social media at the
moment does suggest
that there are no vehicles around that
there are people who have been knocked
over
uh by this uh by this vehicle travelling
there was an
estimate again this is unofficial
someone estimating that it was going at
70 kilometers an hour now
even if that is an over estimate
anything
in that ballpark in a pedestrianized
zone we've all gone been through these
sort of pedestrianized areas of
large towns and you go carefully even if
you're in a vehicle even if you're
allowed to
i think common sense suggests that
people generally drive pretty slowly
if this car was going at anything like
that speed of course that is
a terrifying sight and a car going at
that speed
colliding with pedestrians is very
likely to cause
significant injury okay adam parsons
thanks very much
indeed we will continue to